so I'm like kind of scared to try the
extra spicy but I feel like we should I
mean this is
heat eaters we're flushing that's hard
it's hot yes is it getting hot you guys
have water let's go
let's go this is really spicy
oh my
on today's episode we are exploring all
things Mala spice am I talking to this
camera or yeah to Bill come on bill act
natural ready this is my ultimate spice
craving and I'm really really excited
because we're in kind of the spice Haven
flush in Queens and we're gonna visit
Jason Wang of Xi'an Famous food and then
later on we're going to meet with my
good friend Bobby Flay and I'm going to
introduce him to some shangdu hot pot
let's go
my gosh I haven't been here in Forever
this is my favorite sign of Jason he's
so funny not spicy equals not as good
preach Jason let's head on in I see him
over there Jason hey
welcome oh my God yeah of course
a little setup here yeah I couldn't keep
this open for you
yeah there you go I'll say what are you
in the mood for what do you want to eat
so obviously I'm here for the Spice yeah
Mala spice is something that I crave
yeah almost like on a weekly basis it's
a drug right yeah for us you know I
think the spicy and tingly beef yeah
will be a good choice for you today okay
we use this like a muscle cut which is a
mixture of lean meats fatty Meats as
well as tendons okay some people are a
little put off by that but I like it
just because I love tendons yeah it's
the variation right that's what's
interesting you don't want to bite into
something that's like just the same
texture throughout right yeah but first
we got to make the noodles I
wanting to make these noodles what's in
a dough so the dough is just wheat flour
water a little bit of salt for each
portion of noodles we're going to serve
in our store we have uh we're gonna use
two of these pieces okay boom boom we're
gonna roll it a little bit and then
we're just gonna indent it
why is to dry the shape of the noodle as
you pull it okay pull it and sort of
past the width of your uh shoulder okay
and then you start swing up and down and
you want to get to like four feet five
feet somewhere in between and at this
point you see this that's your
indentation right so we just rip it
apart drop this one right into the water
water and how long does it cook for
three minutes at least okay
we gotta get the culture right so same
thing we gotta get these in soon just
because we don't want it to you know
cook for different amounts of time
pretty easy right pretty easy go for it
go for it so if I learned correctly yeah
there you go yeah all right all right
all right and then we're gonna do this
yep perfect so you stretch first and
then you want to pull it to just past
your shoulder and then start swinging it
try to avoid like the arm movements yeah
also just the wrist and let the weight
of the noodles jump up and down you know
yes yeah
I messed up
but it was my first time
you're such a Critic of herself uh all
right you could drop it right in there
right in here yeah yeah perfect
they're fine I mean no it looks pretty
pretty awesome they look handmade they
look handmade it's very good so what
we're doing right now is just we're
gonna dress the noodles the um the
vegetables first
the aromatics mix there and then some of
that cabbage and then the vinegar and
soy sauce mix which we call noodle sauce
hit me with the noodle sauce yo I'm
adding the chili oil we also got to have
the actual spices and the chili on this
one right we have our stew here this has
the Szechuan peppercorn in it among some
of our chili oil as well after
everything is in the pot we're gonna
just mix it together be like it looks
pretty spicy though it's good right you
need the balance between the vinegar the
soy the salty
oh my God it smells so good okay yeah
yeah the chili is one dimension of this
slice right the chili oil itself already
has 30 different spices right the beef
also has more whole spices while it's
being cooked things like you know
cardamom or Star Anis among other stuff
right I read that Xi'an food takes
influence from like Middle Eastern
flavors as well so like lots of cumin
cardamom like you mentioned the food is
sort of like this rip Richa tapestry of
the history it's sewn together Chinese
middle eastern you know like including
India and then there's Africa even
European influences you know it's time
tested it's it's like tried and true
it's really been around for so long that
um we really really trust in these
flavors
[Music]
look at this look at this
look at these expertly pulled noodles I
wonder who made them
first thing you get is that chili just
like hits you in the face but it's a
combination of the spices that make this
so special in place of cumin you can
taste the cardamom can taste the Chili
Peppers
there's something in the spice that's
really Smoky that I really love
and you really get that tingly oh I'm
starting to get that tingly mouth feel
the Szechuan peppercorn
try some of the beef I could do more
spice famous last words I know it's
amazing though like the tingliness in
your mouth it's so addictive
I can't stop eating it
try it you can put the camera down now I
gotta always be filming you know
deep the best job in the world all right
what's up I cannot stop eating this dude
you want extra spicy I got you so what
do we have spicy tofu custard yo this to
me is the best thing bomb.com that's
what I was old people were saying now
yeah but yeah that's kind of old it is
right
what is this this is actually what makes
for famous in the first place so this
dish is straight out of flushing uh 18
years ago my father started first
serving this dish in the U.S this is it
means cold skin and it's a great summer
dish like today is a hot day sweating a
little bit uh this dish is perfect for
that super chewy noodles
the spice hits you definitely
a lot more so than the hot noodles I
think it sort of pierces through the
taste buds a little bit more right cold
noodles is great for the summer time and
uh you know but it's really a test for
them
the the heat builds
you can't breathe it yeah you gotta be
careful which whichever you gotta like
strategically time your breathing I know
people think like oh you can't handle a
spice or something no I don't have it
it's not it exactly it's not it one of
the things that I feel like is so
popular is the Lamb skewers oh yeah
something I grew up with as a kid
actually in Xi'an I actually didn't like
eating I was really skinny kid I really
sought out actually sought out eating um
you know lamb skewers so yeah we should
definitely hit up with spotting and
flushing I do want to try it I
accidentally touched my nose after
touching the chili pepper so now my nose
is like tingly and it hurts
like you want an extra spicy mix I know
right oh my God
okay
all right so here we are
wow land for sure is always the Mainstay
chicken skin
chicken skin yeah okay I'll try that I
don't usually get that one I do like
eating chicken skin yeah so let's do
that
uh spicy of course spicy
we like it spicy what's that um spice
that he's putting on top that is the
chili powder probably similar to the
ones we use maybe not the exact same
pepper but the idea is the same you want
to you know the meat is still hot it's
still caramelized you put the spices on
it roasts it right on the meat it also
sticks to it the fat on the skewers
actually kind of make a chili oil almost
yeah as you're turning the beef exactly
are flavorful you can smell the spices
this is the real wheel yes the real real
and they're really small pieces of lamb
is that something that's pretty
traditional in these skewers or do it if
you think this is small when I was
growing up it's like the sticks were
like metal sticks and they were like
very thin almost like wire like and the
meat was maybe like
and that's a really good thing though
even though yes it's harder to like
get filled up with it but flavor-wise
flavor the much more surface area
so [__] good yeah
thank you
that is so [__] and it's like not
gaming what do you think Bill well
obviously he loves it obviously Jason
thank you so much
[Music]
thank you so much Jason you're the best
let's go get the drink soon let's get
drinks let's get screwed next time we
could have karaoke and skewers yes yes
yes
it's a hot day hot day for some hot food
we're in Chinatown so we have to get
some boba
thank you
I saw the sign that it says to stir it
like 18 times very specific 18 times
mmm
oh my God Young
this is gonna heal me for my next meal
[Music]
you're the one that's always late so
when you want to find like really
traditional uh delicious like Sichuan
food this is where you go okay great so
this mall it's called New World Mall
first floor if you go that way there's
like a huge food court which is really
interesting and then second casual very
very casual little food stalls typical
Mall food court yeah and then there's a
shopping mall here which you can get
like the craziest groceries you know
Chinese grocery stores are insane it's
like it's like going to Italy but
Chinese yeah like you could get frog
frog yeah
frog what do you do with that
I don't know because that's one thing I
haven't cooked with have you ever cooked
with frogs there's no frog and green
food
not really it's more like Chinese
yeah absolutely yeah do you like it yeah
I do you know tastes like chicken
exactly it really does though so this is
this is the restaurant I'm taking it to
oh this is where we're going yeah this
is where we're going it's called Xiang
Hapa also known as spice world I like
that this is really pretty yeah it's
gorgeous in here and really fun you
smell the Sichuan peppercorn you make
reservation
so
this is really fun have you had Hotpot
before not in a restaurant I feel like
hot pot is the experiential dining okay
like it's it's like the induction in the
middle you get a huge pot of boiling
broth and then all the vegetables and
meats come raw and then you cook it
yourself this one is special because
Sichuan it has this like specific type
of spice to it called Mala Szechuan
peppercorns right Szechuan peppercorns
and chili and then there's like
different colors of Sichuan peppercorns
right yes there's red there's green
there's black right and Szechuan
peppercorns are special because it gives
you that numbing yeah Ma is like the
numbing and La is the spicy so this menu
is kind of crazy it's like one of those
menus where you check off what you want
yeah I'm gonna let you do this because
well I have no idea what I'm doing 10
different types of broths we can get all
right I think it's a good idea to always
get one super spicy and one very mild so
that you know you have something to
balance it I want to taste flavors of
the chilies I want to taste the flavors
of whatever the chilies are sort of
enhancing Etc and a lot of people just
think of Chili's as being hot the bottom
line is every chili or most chilies have
an incredible flavor but you have to get
past the heat to get to the fruitiness
with the earthiness or the smokiness or
whatever it is I cook with chilies for
accent not injury right that said I'm in
your car I'll do whatever you want to do
okay I mean this is
heat eaters we're in Flushing
um so we'll do one extra spicy and then
I'm thinking we'd either do chicken
broth or pork bone broth
[Music]
is better okay so we'll do that wait
there's a pina colada on here
hello there's a bear in it yeah
wow that's beautiful
wow
the bear is made with beef Tallow and
this is the broth so this is the chicken
broth and then he's about to pour
the broth in here and then it melts the
there
the bear is a quicksand
he's out of here he's so cute
all right Bill take a look at the bear
Mr bear
oh my God
[Music]
I'm sorry Mr bear
is just a pina colada this is the great
thing it's like going to the beach and
having hot pot at the same time should I
try the spicy one you want to try it
okay
what do you think spicy
spicy it's not that spicy no
is it
[Music]
not yet we have to let the chilies
really go to work right for this style
hot pot the more you eat the spicier it
gets and in like 30 minutes you're gonna
be like dying plans
oh they have to open up mm-hmm so the
great thing about Hot Pot I feel like
after you put in a lot of these
ingredients it just gets better and
better yeah because the broth gets
flavored by all the different things
that you put inside
it's starting to get hot
is it yeah
it's getting hot yeah
are you okay I'm getting like really hot
I haven't finished the show for you
I have to take off my jacket that's when
you know it's getting good here's where
I'm just gonna get my hands dirty I'm
just going to add everything into the
broth here
because I feel like the veggies hold a
lot of that broth so the veggies
napa cabbage which is my favorite in hot
pot so I'm just gonna start adding
and I always like ripping it with my
hands because
it's like smaller pieces easier to eat
this is a chrysanthemum this is my
favorite in here as well you love that
yeah I love this so I just go crazy
and then mushrooms
yeah yeah I feel it on my lips right
here
you guys have water
I'm gonna need some milk soon
oh oh my god
um
it's spicy it's it just ramps up it just
knocks on the door and says we're a
little spicy and then all of a sudden
they knock the door you're sweating they
knocked out they knocked the door down
that's crazy
I'm sorry I gotta pull my nose
we'll be right back after this
commercial oh this is
that looks gorgeous
this is so fun Esther let me just tell
you something okay because I want to
tell you about my uh my emotions right
now
because it's hot but you know what's
happened and this is what happens with
chilies before you jump into a pool
that's cold you don't want to jump in
but once you get used to it then you're
fine my body is actually starting to
adjust
yeah yeah
I know I want to show you one of the
very trendy Hot Pot tricks which I don't
think works but okay so you take your
meat
then you twirl it and then you cook it
I just did that look
how was that
you ever saw okay I'm gonna try to
because I feel like this doesn't work
because then it Cooks the meat unevenly
oh my God
I know that you are a mentor to a lot of
cooks and chefs
like me how do you pick out Talent
that's a really great nobody's ever
asked me that I don't look for skills
when it comes to people that I want to
Mentor really no it's not about the
skills it's about the attitude and the
work ethic I'm interested in people that
really want to learn how to cook and
take their skills to wherever they want
to take it now years ago it was like do
you want to be on TV or do you want to
cook in a restaurant those days are over
now it's all sort of kind of Blended
together and that's a good thing which
just means there's there's a lot of
amazing opportunities for people who
want to cook professionally in this
world the most important thing and this
is something I tell everybody just keep
focused on what you're doing in terms of
your restaurants and your cooking
because at some point if you just think
oh if I get a TV show I'm good that's
the beginning of the end you can always
crawl back on your on your career which
is you can always open your knife and
start cooking anywhere in the world and
that's that's something that somebody
can't take away from you so do you think
that this they are a good cook here yeah
I actually yeah the chicken brought this
crazy flavorful it's so crazy right but
this is like this literally changes
every 45 seconds it's so cool
it's crazy hot right now and it goes
really well with a pina colada do you
drink though you were sweaty
you're sweating it's good thank you for
introducing me to this oh my gosh of
course I was like I want to bring Bobby
to Hot Pot because I know that this is a
style of eating you don't see often
exactly and you do have to kind of Trek
all the way to Flushing Chef thank you
so much oh it's my pleasure
let's do it again yeah well I'm not done
yeah we're gonna we're gonna keep eating
[Music]
put it in oh look at the front
what's that what's up
[Music]
I like it I like your budget on this
show but oh this is the one View
oh my God dungeon is crap
[Music]
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching oh God that was
spicy
please like And subscribe and to watch
more episodes click here